this seems nowhere clearer than in a
recent broadcast by Nick Cannon you
remember Nick Cannon Nick Cannon is an
actor he's a musician sort of he's been
a pop-culture figure for decades at this
point Nick Cannon decided to broadcast
yesterday not on even his radical left
ideology you know like when we think of
Marxism or something now is something
like that he broadcast on a radical left
racial ideology the mirror image of Nazi
KKK Ku Klux Klan you know that the thing
the left is always talking about we got
to get rid of racism we need anti racism
well it turns out they're anti racism so
often is just the mirror image just as
bad only directed against the other guy
Nick Cannon preached about the power of
melanin let's go to what it really is
then when we talk about the power of
Mellon ated people when we talk about
who we really are as gods and right and
and that melanin is so power and it
connects us in a way that the reason why
they fear black the reason why they
fears because they the lack that they
have of it so then when you see what's
you know dr. Francis II wasn't talked
about is that fear in that that they
genetically should have a person that
has has the lack of pigment the lack of
melon right that they know that they
will be annihilated
so therefore however they got the power
they they have the lack of compassion
that melanin comes with compassion
melanin comes with sold and we know we
call it soul with soul brothers and
sisters
that's the melanin that connect all the
people that don't have it have are are
lit and I'm gonna say this carefully
yeah are a little less and and in where
the term actually comes from cuz I'm
bringing it all the way back around okay
it's a Minister Farrakhan okay there we
go now my eyes go up this is Minister
Farrakhan Farrakhan Louis Farrakhan is a
complete degenerate I is a
racial identity Rhian he espouses
horrific Layher ethically use on
religion and his religion is grounded
primarily in race we've heard this kind
of thing before you remember when a
Nicholas Sandman that Covington kid who
was going down to the pro-life rally
with his Catholic High School and he was
just standing on the National Mall
minding his own business he had a hat
said make America great again hat that
is promoted by the president of United
States and this group of kids was
heckled by a group of black supremacists
called the Hebrew Israelites and they
were screaming all sorts of terrible
things at him and then that crazy Native
American dude walked up to him start
banging a drum in his face kid behave
very well and was destroyed in the press
and by the press and he's won a lot of
judgments against them we've heard this
sort of thing before from people we
would call cultural Marxists in the
Academy there there was one professor
Jeffries this was decades ago who had a
theory of the Sun people and the ice
people the Sun people were black people
who got you know although nice warm rays
of the Sun and the ice people those were
white people they were less than as as
Nick Cannon is saying now I being
Sicilian I think I get a nice little
middle ground here a little more melanin
nated but this is a patently absurd
theory isn't it and it's it's merely
used you know without any basis in
science or history it is used as a way
to put down a group of people on the
basis of their race we always hear about
people being put down on the basis of
their race if they are people of color
but what Nick Cannon is doing is putting
then white people on the basis of their
races saying they're less than they
don't have a soul he says that they're
savages they had to be savages they had
to be barbaric they had because they're
in these Nordic mountains they're in
these rough torrential environments so
they they're acting as animals right so
they're the ones that are actually
closer to animals they're closer to
animals okay that's the kind of stuff we
can expect from Nick Cannon now it's one
thing when you hear some wacko like
Lewis Farrakhan say this it's another
thing when you're some wacko like Nick
Cannon say this but the kind of
that these guys are saying it's not just
heard from these kooky guys in the
culture or even professor like Lionel
Jeffries talks about the Sun people in
the ice people this kind of stuff is
being heard at newspapers like the New
York Times where we see we've seen
multiple articles about abolishing
whiteness the problems of whiteness this
is now infiltrated the mainstream left
what used to be called the mainstream
liberal left Nick Cannon did get fired I
guess he had a contract with Viacom CBS
and he did get fired here here's the
statement that Viacom CBS sent out
Viacom CBS condemns bigotry of any kind
and we categorically denounce all forms
of anti-semitism we have spoken with
Nick Cannon about an episode of his
podcast
Canon's class on YouTube which promoted
hateful speech and spread anti-semitic
conspiracy theories because part of this
video is he spreads this theory also
spread by the Hebrew is realized in
other black supremacist groups that the
that black people American blacks are
the true Hebrews the Israelites the Jews
of the Bible and that the Jews who we
all know as Jews they're like the fake
juice or something like that what's so
striking to me about this statement from
vikon CBS it only it only condemns in
specific terms bigotry against Jews but
all the bigotry that we just heard in
that video was against white people
generally he's talking about what but
that's okay
Viacom doesn't condemn that bigotry that
bigotry is perfectly fine in fact in
many quarters of the popular culture
it's encouraged which is why you hear
these calls to abolish whiteness you
hear things like toxic whiteness you see
city governments now forcing their
employees to go through mandatory
re-education programs where they can
learn about their terrible whiteness and
other racist and they've got to they've
got to get rid of all of their white
privilege
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description